just tell us what has your life been
like since you arrived
in the uk
it's good and it changed so good
yeah
and you've
you've been in school haven't you malala
just tell us about your school and your
classmates
yeah my classmates were good and when i
first
got to my school so i didn't have so
much friends and now i can i have
friends and i'm happy and i'm happy in
my school
i mean
your english is is really good did you
know english before you came to the uk
have you been learning it uh since
you've been here
yeah
yeah i i was learning it when i didn't
came to england
in afghanistan so that's why my english
is good
excellent and tell us a little bit about
being in school then malala
what are your favorite lessons i used to
love doing pe which didn't really help
me much with this job but what are your
favorite lessons
it's maths
maths
excellent i was no good at that either
science
uh i'm good i'm good at it but i like it
and i'm good at it
it's always good
to like what you're good at milani i'm
very pleased to hear that and
how has it been to try and make new
friends i know that you said you didn't
have many when you first got here
but now you have lots more
it was hard
without friends
but now it's okay
and what kind of things do you guys get
up to when you're hanging i mean i
suppose you're not doing maths quizzes
in the in the playground do you guys
have games that you play
tell us a little bit about your life in
the school
yeah we played and
it was games in the ground so we played
on it
and
not
sure and i study
i'm i'm gonna study uh but i'm not good
at english that's why i'm not gonna
study in here
well studying is difficult i'm sure
you've got plenty of other things that
keep your interest a lot more now you
say you like maths do you have plans for
what you want to do when you get older
yeah um i want to be a doctor or a
scientist
so to say that one more time
i want to be a doctor or a scientist
ah very very noble professions i hope
that you are able to achieve that
and what kind of doctor would you would
you want to work in a hospital you would
you want to work kind of locally what
kind of uh of
medical makeup
in a hospital
i want to make my own
oh well that is magnificent
so your plan would be to go back to
afghanistan and help those who are still
there
i wonder malala do you ever get to speak
to any of your family members that are
still in afghanistan if any any of them
are still there
yeah i do
i do every day
oh that's really good it's good to have
that connection and and how are they are
they are they are they coping all right
yeah
they're good and they're saved like
whatever happened in there
okay
look it's been really nice to talk to
you this morning um continue with your
studies as i said maths is excellent and
we always need good doctors all around
the world and the fact that you want to
open a hospital in afghanistan it's a
wonderful wonderful ambition i wish you
all the best of luck okay thank you
malala have a good day
bye thank you